At the risk of sounding like perpetually disappointed
Republican Senator Susan Collins, I have to
tell you guys, I'm really disappointed in
some of my fellow Twitter followers.
Former President George W. Bush, a war criminal
for sure.
Okay.
You're hearing you say it right up at the
top.
George W. Bush put out a video which he narrated
calling for unity and action on Corona virus.
It's a totally uncontroversial video from
a very controversial person.
Okay.
I posted it to my Twitter page over the week
and then I pointed out when George W. Bush
sounds reasonable, you know, you have incompetent
and impotent leadership.
This was, of course, not me praising George
W. Bush, but I was pointing out that when
someone as horrible as George.
W. Bush is able to just put together a reasonable
statement while our current president is unable
to even sound remotely like a normal person,
even one time when talking about the virus.
It proves how bad our leadership is.
That was the point that I was making.
And a ton of people reacted by saying, David,
you are rehabilitating a war criminals reputation.
And of course, it's the opposite.
It's reminding ourselves that, you know, man,
George W. Bush was so bad and he sounds completely
normal in this video because our current president
is off the wall bonkers.
But the best part of it all is that this was
a completely mild and milquetoast video by
George W. Bush just calling for political
unity, and it completely triggered Donald
Trump.
So let's look first at the video, then we'll
talk about the Trump component.
This is a challenging and solemn time in the
life of our nation and world.
Remorseless, invisible enemy threatens the
elderly and vulnerable among us.
A disease that can quickly take breath in
life.
Medical professionals are risking their own
health for the health of others, and we're
deeply grateful.
Officials at every level are setting out the
requirements of public health that protect
us all.
So I think you get it.
You can find the full three minute video online.
It's just a call to unity.
That's all it is.
It's completely uncontroversial.
And Donald Trump couldn't take it.
Donald Trump called out Bush for not supporting
him in his impeachment trial.
If you can imagine something more absurd,
Trump first quotes Pete Hegseth from Fox News,
of course, saying Pete Hegseth said, oh, by
the way, I a priest, by the way, by spelled
BYU.
Oh, by the way, I appreciate the message from
former President Bush.
But where was he during impeachment calling
for putting partisanship aside?
And then Trump himself adds.
Bush was nowhere to be found in speaking up
against the greatest hoax in American history.
So Trump is not only highly triggered, but
he seems to be equating the pandemic to his
own impeachment.
Impeachment, of course, a political process
which was completely warranted by the facts.
And it was completely partisan.
Now, Trump may see it as Democrats conspired
against me without evidence in impeachment.
But there is no analogy to corona virus that
the Corona virus conspire against Trump.
Now, what Trump would argue is he handled
it all perfectly.
And yet Democrats and I guess former Republican
President Bush are all conspiring to claim
Trump did a bad job.
But there is really no analogy in this.
You know, his impeachment being like the virus
is an endlessly narcissistic comment to make.
But notice the ease with which George W. Bush
triggers Donald Trump merely by saying, hey,
let's not be horrible partisans.
Let's come together on this.
Let's protect people.
Let's do the right thing.
And Trump sees that as an attack.
It says way more about Trump than it does
about Bush.
Now, I want to go back again, pointing out
that George W. Bush put out a normal statement.
Doesn't mean I'm saying anything positive
about George W. Bush.
I'm pointing out that even George W. Bush,
a terrible, immoral president, was able to
put out a statement that sounds completely
normal in a time of crisis.
What it shows us is how uniquely unhinged
Trump is.
It says nothing good about George W. Bush.
Some people just want to see the left eat
itself and even people on the left want to
see that.
You know, pointing out that Biden is better
than Trump is not supporting sexual assault.
Pointing out George W. Bush is better than
Trump is not rehabilitating the reputation
of a war criminal.
Let's get it together, guys.
We've got very important things going on.
We've got to remove this president.
We're dealing with a pandemic.
It think the stakes are too high to be eating
ourselves at this point in time.
Let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at Deep Packman.
We will take a quick break.
And we have oh, so much more coming up
for you today.